(upbeat music)
- Well, welcome back to another
episode of the "Addy Hour".
Again, I'm honored to be able
to host these conversations
and stay really honored again,
and excited to be able to
jump into a conversation topic
that we haven't addressed
up to this point,
and that's really thinking
about mental health
in the military.
So today I'm honored to be
able to host three guests
for a conversation about mental health,
the military, and the
unseen wounds of war.
The first guest I'd like to
introduce is Steven Elliott.
Steven is a veteran of
the war in Afghanistan,
having served there as
an army ranger in 2004.
He's also the author of
"War Story", a memoir,
in which he details his journey
to and from the battlefield,
and the reality of the
unseen wounds of war.
It's a really great book,
very compelling story
and important narrative,
which I've read.
So I encourage you to check it out
if you haven't read it already.
Also did want as mention Steven
as someone who has been featured
on ESPN, NPR, NBC Fox
News, MSNBC, and others,
and the hope that he
and his family's story
would help others also
find hope and healing.
He's someone who's a native of Kansas,
he's currently an entrepreneur
and resides in Southern California
with his wife and two daughters.
And someone I was able to
connect with a few years back,
glad that we have this
opportunity to reconnect.
I wanna make sure I
welcome Stephen Elliott
to the "Addy Hour" podcast.
- Thanks for having me.
- Of course.
The next guest I'd like to introduce
is Ellsworth "Tony" Williams.
Tony is someone who is
a combat army veteran,
having faithfully and
honorably served an active duty
in the army for 24
years, eight and listed,
and 16 years commissioned.
This includes service during Desert Storm,
Operation Iraqi Freedom and
Operation Enduring Freedom.
He's also someone who's
received numerous awards
including a Bronze Star
and three Meritorious Service Medals.
One thing that I really admire about Tony
is that after he retired in 2007,
he actually decided to rebrand himself
and get a master's degree
in Clinical Mental Health
Counseling from Troy University.
Upon graduation, he founded
and is currently the president
and CEO of Veterans Counseling Veterans,
and he continues in this
really important work.
I will mention this on the side,
I watched one of the
recent updates that he did,
and I was really encouraged by the energy
that he brought as he was
dancing to Pharrell's "Happy"
at the beginning of that update,
and I thought that was great
just to be able to lead off in that way.
Wanna make sure I welcome
"Tony" Williams here
to the "Addy Hour" podcast.
Thanks for being here.
And the third guest who
I'd like to introduce
is Dr. Barbara Rothbaum,
who is the director
of the Emory Healthcare Veterans Program,
and also the director
of the Trauma and Anxiety
Recovery Program at Emory.
She holds numerous titles
and has lots of honorary titles as well,
but I did just want to
mention some of her work
that she has also been involved in.
Dr. Rothbaum is someone
who specializes in research
on the treatment of anxiety
disorders, particular PTSD.
She's also been able to contribute
to lots of conversations
and to reports around policy as well,
and has briefed the Department of Defense,
the Veterans Association
or Veterans Affairs,
the House and Senate
Committees on Veterans' Affairs
and the Armed Services Committees
on the Institute of Medicines report
around some of these topics.
Dr. Rothbaum is someone who's
been studying PTSD treatments
since 1986, and she has also developed,
tested and disseminated
some of the most innovative
and effective treatments
available for PTSD,
which I'm sure we'll talk about today.
She's also authored
numerous scientific papers,
has also published over 11 books.
The most recent of which is entitled
"PTSD for the General Public:
PTSD What Everyone Needs to Know".
So again, someone who has
a long standing history
and effort and effectiveness in this work,
and we're grateful to be
able to welcome Barbara
to the program today as well.
- Thank you for having me.
- Of course.
So as my listeners know,
I always just start out
checking in with everybody
to see how everyone is
doing at this moment
as we are at the end of February of 2022.
And with everything that
we continue to experience,
I think it's just helpful
to kind of center our conversation there
as a launching point.
So I'm really gonna reverse
order of our introductions
and actually start with Barbara.
- I'm very excited.
So we've pivoted back and forth
with our veteran program over COVID.
With the beginning, we went telemedicine,
we came back with the omicron
variant and the surge.
In January, we went
telemedicine (indistinct).
Again, this week we've brought
people back in person again,
so it's just exciting to
have veterans on site again.
- Well, that's wonderful to hear,
I know that's been quite a journey.
And just from what I've seen
from some of the work you all done,
seems that you pivoted pretty well
in terms of really
getting the message across
to let people know the
surges were available
and still highly effective,
but I'm sure it's exciting
to come back in person.
- Yeah, no, they are.
And we gather data on everything we do,
and we're so thrilled that
our telemedicine treatment
is just as effective, but it's
nice to have people on site.
- Yeah, yeah, definitely, I agree.
Tony, how about you?
How are you doing these days?
No, I wasn't,
I don't know if you're gonna
dance for us as well, but
(Addy chuckles)
I think you're on mute.
- So where's the music playing?
So, I tell you, one thing about,
'cause I'm basically introverted
and this COVID forced me
to become more extroverted
with my virtuals.
So it wasn't for that, you
would not have seen me on.
So most of the stuff I've done,
which have been in person,
which really is only people
who are there know it exists.
And because of the
amicron and stuff going,
and all that stuffs going on
and it forced to do all
my events virtually,
which now has increased
people that see what I do.
So that, and one side of it,
I've seen some positive as far
as that reaching more people
and some of that.
And accessible, as a nonprofit
is definitely more economical
to do it virtual versus these
events that we're going in.
So that's a good thing here.
I'm still trying to monitor how COVID,
and I'm hopefully, these guests
can talk about a little bit,
is how has COVID affected suicide?
You know, that's my name, bread and butter
when it comes to the
military and veterans,
'cause you know,
I have, everything I know is anecdotal,
and if you really see those,
so many reports to come out
from the DOD, you've
seen something different.
So I'm definitely curious to
hear from these guests here,
have they seen any kind of differences
when it comes to COVID
in the veteran space?
- Yeah, that's definitely a topic
we should definitely make
sure we loop back to.
Encouraged to hear that
in a way the silver lines
that you've been able to expand your reach
in some ways as well, so.
I applaud for taking advantage of that
and being flexible, again,
just in the moment that
we're in as well, so.
Steven, how about you, how
are you doing these days?
- Doing okay.
We had the last couple
years have been certainly
what they've been for all of our society.
And we decided to throw in a move
from the Seattle area
of Southern California,
just 'cause we thought
that'd be fun (indistinct).
And so yeah, it's been a weird,
the last couple years have been, you know,
the problems that we've had
to deal with in our household,
you know, I'll take those any day
over the ones that a lot of
people had to struggle with.
So I found myself much more inward focused
than I would like to be,
just in terms of navigating a move
and navigating changes and
enterprises I'm engaged with
that are kind of resolving
and yeah, really grateful.
I mean, our household is healthy
and we just feel really fortunate
to be where we're at and, yeah.
And I don't know if
excited is the right word,
but certainly, ready to,
whatever extent we can,
continue to reengage in this conversation.
So yeah, happy to be here.
- Excellent.
Again, sounds like a lot
of flexibility and some,
I don't know what the right word is,
bravery maybe, on your part,
moving it in the middle,
but it sounds like things are.
(Addy chuckles)
- It worked out.
We started the process prior to COVID
and I continued with that process
and yeah, again, it's, you know, you know,
moving is what it is,
but that's self-imposed and
we're on the other side of it
and (indistinct).
- Right, right.
- Glad to be here, so.
- Yeah, that's wonderful to hear.
Now I appreciate it, in the way
that you put everything in context
to even just acknowledging
what challenges you have had,
but also knowing that there
are lots of other things
that a lot of people have
gone through to be clear.
And I think that ties
into a lot of the stories
and the work that you all do as well.
So before we kinda jump
into some of the the meat
of the conversation, so to speak,
I also wanted to give you all a chance
just to talk about the
work and the initiatives
that you're involved in.
So Steven, actually,
if you could start out just
telling us a little bit
about the Elliott Funds
and what you all do as an organization.
- Yeah, the Elliott Fund
was originally established
in conjunction with the
publishing of "War Story"
a few years ago.
Really, there wasn't,
I'd like to say there was
a lot of strategic thought
put into it, there wasn't.
It was simply established
to be a pass through entity
for any book proceeds,
'cause that was one of
the things that, for us,
we felt it was important,
was that if there was
any financial resources
that that book produced,
we wanted to be able to channel
those to other nonprofits
that were doing good work
in the veteran space.
So really, that was, that's
all it was initially,
and then, we've continued to
kind of use that as a platform,
really, of connection between resources
and other organizations.
And right now the main
work that we're doing,
we, being my wife and I, my wife, Brooke,
is we're working closely
with a film producer named Beth Dolan,
who's in the finishing
stages of post-production
for a documentary film
called "Stranger at Home"
that really chronicles the,
it chronicles a story
of a Military Mental Health Whistleblower
named Dr. Mark Russell, who's
a former Naval Commander
and who, in the early stages,
you know, pre-Iraq invasion,
was adamantly raising
concerns as to the gaps
between the DOD state of
policy for mental health
and the actual practical gaps
for how that was applied.
And so that documentary which we've seen,
the rough cut of it's pretty compelling.
We'll be using whatever
resources we have in our platform
to advocate both for that film
and for policy changes within
the active duty component
to help curtail the military
mental health epidemic.
So that's kinda what
we're up to right now.
- That's really encouraging to hear
that you've been able to
continue in those efforts
and some of these important topics.
I'll be curious as we go through,
even with some of Dr Barbara's experiences
to maybe even comment
on some of the things
that she's seen in her
perspective as well.
Before we get there, though,
Tony, I wanted to give you also a chance
to talk a little bit about
Veterans Counseling Veterans
on the heels of what Steven
has just mentioned as well.
- So I founded the Veterans
Council Veterans in 2014
and as I, actually,
after I intern at the VA
and what people don't
understand and don't know,
it's not a slide on them,
but 90% of the providers aren't veterans.
And I realized that
when I was getting the,
my interns and talking to them.
So that's why I came with
the idea of veterans,
why can't veterans council veterans.
And it's a Veterans Council
Veterans is a nonprofit
that consists of veterans
and spouse of veterans
who are in a mental profession.
Doesn't matter, it's almost like a,
it doesn't matter if you're
clinical psychologist
or LCSW, (indistinct).
And so I just wanna
get away from identity,
we try to get away from identity
of being a social worker
and being more of a veteran is helpful
versus I'm a "social worker",
or I'm a "psychologist".
That's, to me, is what breaking, we got,
I wanted to break through.
Veteran Council Veterans,
its prior mission
is suicide prevention,
veteran suicide prevention.
And we do this with the
model we call TEAMS,
is teaching education,
advocacy, mentorship,
and services, and many arenas.
And so, and we try to take the risk factor
and turn it to protective facet.
One of the things that
is different from us
is that people don't understand that,
don't realize that over
about 7% of the military,
of the veterans, have a
relationship, one way or the, okay?
So we, you know, you lose that,
when you're in the service,
they get as much service as you get,
but once you get out of the service,
it's just a veteran that
gets all the services.
And so I wanted to make
sure I include them
in everything I do when it comes to that.
So we focus, not just on the veteran,
we also focus on the family as well,
so is in the family, so is in the veteran.
So those are the things we
have and we come up next week,
we're doing a Veterans' Family
Mental Wellness Workshop
for the veterans' families.
We're gonna do a Military
Psycho-trauma Workshop,
and we're gonna have a summit as well.
Military Veterans, Suicide
Veteran Summit, our fourth one,
and it's gonna have faith,
peers, mental health,
and the community, you need all four
to have any kind of (indistinct).
Veterans suicide is a national problem,
but it has a local solution.
You cannot nationalize it,
you can't franchise it,
and you can't monopolize it.
You have to look at the local
community to really fix it.
You can't take something, like right now,
one of my biggest concerns
is that whenever you have a
crisis, you call this number,
it's a VA number, but
they're all in Kannadiga.
Okay, why do I gotta call Kannadiga?
My house is on fire down the street,
why do I call on the fire
department in New York
to put my house out?
So we gotta get away from that,
that's the thing I'm
trying to push as much
we gotta start involving
more of the community
when it comes to suicide prevention,
intervention, and postvention.
So that's my thing.
Thanks, (indistinct).
- Of course, and thanks so
much for that description.
I mean, it's encouraging and
to hear the holistic approach
that you're using as well.
And again, just the innovative concept
of veterans counseling veterans
and how you've been able to
make progress in that as well.
Barbara, also to pivot to you,
and have you tell us a
little bit about the programs
that you direct as well, if you could.
- Right, so I direct the Emory
Healthcare Veterans Program.
We are funded by
philanthropy in a large grant
from the Wounded Warrior Project,
so many, many thanks to WWP.
We can bring in Post-9/11 veterans
from all around the country.
We bring them into our place in Atlanta,
set them up in a hotel near our clinic,
and we give them a lot
of treatment every day,
for two weeks, it's called an
Intensive Outpatient Program.
They get a lot of individual therapy,
we do evidence-based therapy,
so that's therapy that
has been shown in studies
to be helpful.
We treat PTSD, depression, anxiety,
we've got specific tracks
for substance use or misuse,
we've got a track for mild
traumatic brain injury,
we've got interventions for pain,
we teach everybody yoga, they
can have acupuncture for pain.
So we've got family
surfaces, even before COVID.
We involved the family via telemedicine,
'cause we really want people
to eat, breathe and sleep the
program while they're here,
but we involve the
family via telemedicine.
And we, everything is at
no cost to the veteran,
so transportation, housing.
They get more therapy in two weeks
than most people get in an entire year
and it's effective therapy.
So I don't know if people
know there's a lot of dropout
from PTSD treatment.
I mean, PTSD is a disorder of avoidance
and that means therapy too.
We have a 93% completion rate.
- Wow.
- So I really, I've been
treating PTSD my entire career,
I think this is the way
to treat it, with the IOP.
So every Monday we've got
a new cohort of veterans.
It's a two week program,
so any given time,
we've got people that
it's their first week
and their second week.
So they've got a cohort of veterans
who are also doing the hard work
and they've got our whole team.
We've got psychologists,
social workers, psychiatrists,
neuropsychiatrist, we've got
Veteran Outreach Coordinators,
we've got everybody
who's trying to help them
and give them evidence based treatment.
So I'm very proud of it, and
I'm happy to talk about it
'cause I think we're one
of the best kept secrets
in the nation, and we don't wanna be,
we wanna be full every time.
- Yeah, that's wonderful to hear.
Really, again, I appreciate
the work that you've been doing
and it struck me, as you've been talking,
some of the overlapping themes
between the three of you
in terms of the efforts
and the ways that these
aren't narrow efforts
in one specific pocket,
but just trying to make sure
that it really is something
that's broad and across the board.
I mean, we'll definitely dig
into that a little bit more,
but I'll just actually gonna open it up,
not planned a little bit of an audible,
but I'm curious if you all have thoughts
as you've all heard each other talking
about each other's programs
and efforts in a sense,
either in terms of things
that resonate with you
or questions that you have for each other.
So I'm gonna leave that,
I know that's a little wide open,
but I'm just curious how you
all have been kind of listening
into each other and processing
what you all have shared.
- Well, I wanna respond when,
Tony, were talking about,
that we have to pay
attention to veteran suicide
and agree totally.
And, so ours is a clinical program,
but I'm a clinical researcher too,
so we gather data and we look at it
to make sure what we're doing is working.
And with one of our sister sites,
we combined data and we were able to see,
when you treat the PTSD effectively,
the suicidal thoughts decrease.
So it, we were, we felt that
the word we hear most often,
it sounds dramatic when I say it,
but when we send people
back to their families,
the word we hear most
often is transformative.
You've given us our Tony back,
but it's, so my approach
is treat what's wrong.
I mean, but that's also
within our holistic
and family approach,
and that that's helpful.
- That's good to hear.
- Yeah, I mean, I heard two things,
one from each of you, which really,
I completely agree with.
One, (indistinct) Dr. Rothbaum
just talking about PTSD
being a, if you would
use the word disease,
but disorder of avoidance,
I mean, that's essentially,
I think that could have been the subtitle
of my story (indistinct) was that.
I mean, when I look at
the resources that I had
on my disposal, but the
narrative of my own pride
and my own avoidance
in terms of not wanting to
really risk hope that like,
what if I put myself out there
and I pursue these various
modalities and treatment
that I didn't understand,
and I was still broken,
well, and then what?
That was part of it,
but, also then the piece of not feeling
that I even deserved to be well.
And so I think, for me,
part of what I experienced
was certainly self-inflicted
in terms of avoiding
whatever help that there was.
And then Tony, something that you said,
which I totally agree with,
is the grassroots up-down approach,
which doesn't preclude
professionals or policy makers.
I mean, we need a web and a net,
all sorts of people within the ecosystem,
but yeah, you're a 100% right.
I mean, I don't know,
there's been a lot of counseling sessions
that have taken place in
bars and probably still do.
(Addy chuckles)
And maybe that's okay, maybe that's,
that's maybe not where
it needs to always stay,
(Elliott chuckles)
but if that's a piece in
the journey, then so be it.
And I think, that's part of it too, is,
how do you get people
that are on that journey
into a place that,
who are generally people
who are very much motivated
by service in the first place?
And that's maybe part of the things
that are depressing them,
and is now they feel like they're useless.
They're not in uniform,
they can't do the thing
that was meaningful
to society anymore, and now
they're thinking about suicide.
The fact that them helping others
is part of their own healing.
I think that's so good
and that's so encouraging.
- You know, Steven and
everybody in the group,
one of the things I always,
when I talk about the locality and local,
when you go to a community
and you ask the best fried chicken,
"So where's the best fried chicken?"
people from there, most of the time,
it's this cranky old,
nasty, old building, right?
With, you know, everything
has fallen down,
but there's a long line, right?
Because the local people
know where the best food is.
If you ask somebody who's not from there,
guess what they're gonna tell you?
KFC, Paparazzi, 'cause
it's a national brand,
but PTSD, I mean, PTSD
suicide is so personal.
You can't get anything more
personal than dying by suicide.
And I think that we got to get past that
using the same scale of the
same way of doing things.
If we wanna really be effective,
we gotta start looking at
people and accessibility.
And Steven you were
talking about how we train
as an kind of, you know,
how we train as a military.
I saw, you didn't say that,
but that's what I heard,
is in the military, we strip
away your individuality, right?
Like wax on the dang floor,
and we put the the stuff down
to take a wax off, and we put
in your whole new identity,
which is the collective.
We don't do a good job out reversing that,
we don't do a good job of taking
that changed energy we put
to make you collective, to
make you think individually.
And so if I was to treat a veteran,
you cannot do it individually,
'cause we don't think like that.
We think collectively,
we think as a patrol,
we think it's a squad, we
think as a (indistinct).
And some of the things
that we call suicide,
over there is considered
heroic action, right?
So if I'm walking down,
and we're in a patrol,
and I see an IED or a bomb in the road,
you know, I wanna protect
the rest of my people.
So I don't think, and
I go and I jump on it,
when no one says suicide, right?
Because then that's considered heroic
and you get a medal and
maybe a Medal of Honor.
But when you take those same things
that are sort of great over there,
and you transpose them over
here, they're now out problems.
You can no longer being hypervigilant,
over there is good, right?
You never know who's
gonna take you anywhere,
so being hypervigilant, looking,
who's that by the corner,
hey, you looking at me (indistinct),
that's part of what it
takes to survive over there,
that you cannot use the
same things you learned
that kept you alive over there, over here.
So I'm just saying that we gotta look at,
and I haven't even talk
about the families,
is a whole done dynamic,
but as an individual, we cannot
keep using the same model
of an individual, and then
trying to think it works for us,
we weren't trained that way.
We were trained like
the Borg on "Star Trek",
we were trained as the
collectors, the collective,
and that's what we were used
to trying to get part of,
that collectiveness and
not that individual,
I wanna be rich.
So I just thought I wanted to relay that
to when Steve was talking
about beating at the bar
or some of the most effective
people, through a suicide,
is not somebody with a PhD
or 3000 letters on the end of the lane,
but it's a regular Joe
that sit through and say,
"Hey man, let's talk."
- Yeah.
- So anyway, that's my
spill with my comment
when it comes to suicide.
- Yeah, really well said.
And I appreciate you
pulling out those nuances
for us as well.
I'm curious for the other two as well,
like how you would react to that,
because it seems that
there's also this tension
between the individual,
but you've also all
alluded to the importance
of the relationships as
well, and their family.
So how have you seen your experience?
How do people walk
through that practically,
still try and get the attention
they need individually,
but now within the context
of other relationships,
not necessarily in the context
of a military relationship?
Any insights or experiences
you all wanna share?
- I can talk for four days about it, yeah.
(Addy and Barbara chuckles)
I'll try not to,
and I'll focus in my
comments right now on PTSD,
but I know we're not
just talking about PTSD.
And I think we tend to believe our stories
and if it's something that's associated
with a traumatic event and
there's a lot of avoidance,
and we don't even wanna think about it,
we don't wanna talk about it,
we don't want anything to remind us of it,
then we can't possibly
think differently about it.
And so what we do is help
people confront those memories,
confront the triggers and
do it in a therapeutic way
that then they can take it
out and they can look at it.
So they might be thinking what happened,
I was, you know, Jones got killed,
it was my fault 'cause I was
driving when we hit the IED.
And if you can't go there,
that's what they're carrying with them.
When we work on it,
they might be able to
change how they think,
that it sucks that Jones got killed,
but as we went through it,
I did everything I could, there
were eight eyes on the road,
it was the insurgent planning that IED.
And so once we can help work them
to have a different perception
of themselves in the world,
I mean, it's kind of what
you guys were saying too,
then that, we translate it completely
by involving the family,
by involving other people
to help work on their
relationships as well.
So it's, you know,
I guess it's a chicken and an egg
and you start wherever you start.
So a lot of times we'll start
with the individual work
and helping people see it more clearly,
and then I think that can help
with some of the relationships.
- So it sounds like stepwise
in that sense as well.
- Yeah.
- Steven, I'd be curious
in your own experience too,
'cause you alluded to avoiding
the hope in that sense
and because of possible disappointment,
is there a way that you can
recall that you were able
to make that transition?
Was it also similarly focused
on you as an individual
or were there other processes or coaches
that were helpful in your situation?
- Well, I mean, for me,
it was just a question of
like how bad it'd have to get
before he wanted to get help.
And for me it took the
point at which, you know,
my wife knew a lot more what was going on
with me than I did,
and it was a point at which, you know,
after X number of years
saying, I wanna divorce.
And then is at that point which,
that was 13 years ago and we're married
and that's a really
blessed part of the story,
but at a certain point you
just sort of find yourself
sitting in a place that
you never intended to go,
at no point did you
look at the map and say,
yeah, I wanna go to moving out
and living with two other single guys
after having been married
and having a house,
that kind of feels like a step backwards,
no offense to that,
but that was not where I was trying to go.
And then, it took a pretty,
yeah, it took a pretty thick
metaphorical two by four for me
to sort of wake up and realize,
maybe if I keep doing or
not doing the same thing,
I'm gonna keep getting the same thing.
And if that's what I want then fine,
but if I want a different result in life,
then maybe I'm gonna have
to try something else.
And I didn't have, I
didn't have a, you know,
for me it was partly a, it
was an absence of context
because I grew up around
a lot of veterans.
My grandfather was a
veteran of World War II,
fought in Italy for a year and a half.
And it wasn't until I was an adult
that I saw the other side of the heroic,
freeing of Europe from the Germans
and realized that war is hell.
And that was something
that he carried with him
through his life, and he
had a community around him.
But for me, like post-traumatic
stress disorder was,
that was a scary acronym.
I didn't know what it meant
other than it meant that I must be weak
to be experiencing this.
And that's difficult
when you've come from
a military experience,
which I think is true
for anybody who joins.
I don't care if you're
a clerk in the air force
or if you're an army ranger
or anything in between,
you join to serve,
you want to operate from
a place of strength,
and you have to be willing
to do difficult things
that some other people
just aren't willing to do.
And so then when you
find yourself in a place
and you know, certainly, the
community that I served in,
that community self-selects poor people
who just put up with a lot of pain,
that's really what it is.
I mean, it's bizarre,
it's an all-volunteer force
that we have right now,
and that was an all-volunteer unit.
The only reason you're
there getting yelled at
and getting put through the pace
is 'cause you choose to be there.
And so then having been
self-selected essentially
for compartmentalizing and focusing
and just accomplishing the task.
I'm not sure whether it's you,
Dr. Rothbaum, who said it,
but essentially then it's that
deprogramming piece to say,
hey, it doesn't make any less tough
to acknowledge the fact that you're hurt
and to acknowledge the fact that,
hey, it's, you know, we don't,
there's no stigma around that
with respect to of physical wounds.
If I get shot, nobody's standing around me
on the battlefield, berating
me for getting shot,
or making me feel guilty.
Even if I did something stupid,
they're gonna care for me.
And so that was certainly
a big part of my journey
within my family.
It was essentially how much,
how bad do I really want this to get?
'Cause it's not going in a good direction.
And is, am I willing to risk?
Which in retrospect,
the risk was, you know,
you see it as this big, but it's really,
it's a lot of people who wanna help you.
(Elliott chuckles)
And it's so much bigger in your mind
than it is in actuality.
So for me, part of that journey
was just having a language
and a context to not embrace the trauma
and have that become who I am,
where then I am, that's
my sole identifier,
is I'm a wounded veteran of
PTSD and that's who I am,
that's my business card or something.
But it's to say that,
no, that's integrated
into part of my experience
and I can actually
experience growth from that,
and I don't have to be
stuck in that place.
And, you know, that growth
takes a lifetime maybe,
but that's okay.
- Yeah, that's really well
said and really powerful,
and appreciated just
your honesty and candor
in that as well.
One thing, I mean, I have so
many things that came to mind,
one thing that did come to mind,
which I'll have you and the
others response to as well,
is just this, I guess the
aspect of choice and volition,
which is a whole big, that's
a whole another topic.
Part of the reason I
bring that up, though, is,
thinking as a neuroscientist too,
and in terms of what we know
about what happens to the brain
during certain situations
and how it can change things,
some people could get
stuck in a certain mindset.
And then also thinking about
some of the different episodes
that we've had,
particularly talking
about mental health needs
and youth and things like that,
and some of the advice some
our clinical psychology experts
have talked about, just
being there for people,
but not pushing people to
say you have to get help,
but knowing that you are
there to support them.
So I'm curious with, Steven,
with everything that you've mentioned
and the others as well, how people,
especially in military
circles and veteran circles,
trying to navigate that
aspect of seeing someone
who you want to be able
to help to move forward,
but then also knowing that,
Steven, as you mentioned,
you had to get to a
place where, in extent,
you desired to move forward
and it got bad enough,
the metaphorical two by four to say,
"Okay, this isn't a situation
that I want to go down the road
and just stay in that place."
And the same time,
and this is probably my
neuroscience frame we're coming to,
knowing that there's so much
that happens in the brain
that keeps certain
patterns happening as well.
So I don't know if I'm
forming this question well,
but just trying to get a
sense of how you navigate that
in your own life,
and in the lives of those
that you love as well,
not push people into treatment per se,
but also encourage and try
and make that come about.
So you all are probably gonna
articulate that a lot better
than I just asked the question,
but just thought that
thought that came to mind.
- Well, imagine we'll
have different answers.
So a lot of times, and our
whole program is set up
to try to break down the barriers to care.
- [Addy] Okay.
- But a lot of it, I
mean, people are saying,
how can treatment help you
can't change what happened?
And that's what I'm suffering
from now is what happened.
And so, part of it, from my point of view,
is education and letting people know that,
yeah, it sucks what happened,
but what you're suffering
from now is whatever,
we'll name it,
and gotta diagnose it or talk about it,
it's PTSD or depression
or substance use disorder
and that we can treat.
And so letting people know that
treatment really does help.
And you guys are the
best messengers we have.
I mean, people who've
graduated from our program,
they're our best PR to
tell other veterans,
you gotta do this, it help.
And you know, Steven, like you,
most of our, well, I
don't know if it's most,
a lot of them are there
because their wives
or husband are saying,
"You gotta get help or I'm outta here."
or sometimes moms and dads,
"You're not the same person that you were,
you gotta do something different."
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I can tell you,
my wife's is a retired
law enforcement officer,
and she's the reason why
I got into counseling,
'cause she was in charge
of domestic violence piece.
And I bring that because it's a,
and I will keep talking about PTSD,
PTSD is just one, it's
just one piece in a way,
it's not the veteran.
A lots of veterans who die about suicide
and that kinda stuff is not
the top three, it's top,
you know, it's relationships,
it's other stuff.
So we're focused on PTSD,
but there's a lot more that
encompasses, if it's suicide,
PTSD is just one of them.
And it starts with a trust factor,
and it's so important that
we have all these studies,
the number one factor is
the therapeutic alliance.
Do they trust you?
Do they feel you care about them?
Do you think you share the
same belief that they care,
that they have?
And that's a challenge
when (indistinct)
Veterans Council Veteran,
generally speaking,
we already come with
the trust factor, right?
When we sit down and talk,
I don't have to sit there,
there's no difference for
me being African American,
if I'm having the George
Floyd thing, who do I think
is gonna more understand the
George Floyd thing, you know?
And that's just the way
we are, we're humans,
we're not robots.
We're gonna go to something
that we're naturally,
my tribe, actually, my tribe
does not have to look like me,
they just have to believe like me,
and then we learn that in the military.
So it's that trust factor.
And because I notice more
and then just the individual,
even with all the programs,
if the family's a part of it,
if you don't adjust the
family, then you really less,
you know, you can go
and be intensive care,
intensive from treatment and have,
your blood pressure's great, eating great,
everything's great.
You go home, your wife,
Molly, is Puerto Rican,
you go home and guess what?
You're right back to that bad food,
because we didn't do anything
to the other part that you go back to.
And that's saying with stresses
and all of those kinda stuff,
that the holistic piece of.
So when I talk to the veteran I aid,
I look at me being like a Walmart.
I'm not there to sit there
and solve your problem,
I'm there to point to you
to the aisle way, aisle six.
You got a headache?
Aisle six, go to the pane G-6, right?
You then make the decision
which one talks to you.
I'm not gonna tell you
this is the best medicine,
I'm gonna say, go to aisle,
and then you decide, when you
look at all the medicines,
which one is, and you feel is the pain,
you wanna try to get.
You know, six seconds,
(indistinct) second,
whatever that thing is.
So we gotta be more, to
me, and we gotta, for me,
from a nonprofit point of
view, I'm not the solution,
there's so many other kinds of
solutions that may not work.
And that's the same thing
I'm bringing on here,
'cause I'm here,
you know, that the different cultures,
Hispanic cultures have
a different, you know,
they are really, really
involved in the family.
And if your family not
part of that solution,
you're really only shooting
the piece to that solution.
And if you're not, and if you
don't understand the language,
you really got a problem,
because now you're trying
to translate to the family
who only speaks, 'cause even
when you get to the second,
when you get pass the veteran,
some of the English language
start getting kinda almost gone,
but you still gotta find a way to get,
if you wanna to really treat them.
So these are things that I try to fade
and I say, and I'm just,
I'm using that part that
everyone understands.
But as Steven understands
the other, the nuances is,
Steven was in a ranger at a time, okay?
Those are bad asses, okay?
They have a totally different
mentality than a clerk
that's counting beans and bullets, okay?
He gets rewarded for a compartmentalizing
and the cognitive, right?
He gets to be rewarded.
If you're a commander
and I was a commander,
and I felt you were going
to jeopardize my mission,
I don't have any so-so determinants,
I don't care about what it looks like.
I care about the mission.
And if I feel like you're
gonna jeopardize the mission,
you're not going, 'cause
the mission's number one.
If you're a ranger, special forces,
those guys, that's like embedded in them.
If you're, but if you're a
different kind, of the force,
again, the clerk, the medics,
the medics, they don't,
they're not kicked down,
kicked doors down and
sniper and everything else,
they're about serving and helping people.
They just wanna help.
So that's where a lot of the
moral injury comes as well,
because your whole being and
belief is about helping people,
and then you see either you
can't that person that just got,
that was killed or whatever,
or if you see a family
get taken out by the IED,
we don't even talk about the
effects of the, you know,
I'm all of military intelligence.
And so when you sit
there and you take a bomb
and you take out the whole grid square,
that's a whole bunch of
generations You just took out,
how you dealing with that?
(Tony chuckles)
What are we doing to deal with that piece?
And that's where the more injury
that Barbara was kind of
talking about and Steve,
there's a more injury piece.
Again, my point is that it is
too personal to do a study,
and you look at the study,
and you only got 10% of the study,
it has one part of the dang population.
You know, if I was to do the same study
and I had the opposite,
and I said that, "Hey, I
got a medicine's gonna work,
but it only works 90%
for African Americans,
10%, we don't know." would
that be evidence based?
Probably not,
(Tony chuckles)
but the reverse, that's just reality.
So when I look at it, I
look at thee counseling
in two phases, the
military and it's nuanced,
but then the other cultures as well,
that's what we gotta deal
with when we start counseling,
not just you being a veteran,
being a special operator or whatever.
But then if you happen
to Hispanic, Indian,
female veteran, military
sergeant, all that,
that also is all a factor that
may take more than just a one
or two weeks intensive
outpatient treatment.
So I'm just throwing at that,
I'm just trying to let you
know that it is not that simple
like people trying to make it out be.
- So anyway, yeah, I'm sorry.
- No, that's great, that's great.
Steven, anything you
wanted to react to there?
- Yeah, I mean, I agree with all that.
I mean, I think it, I mean,
it's certainly multifaceted,
it's certainly unique to the individual
and the context that they
bring to the service.
You know, if you're coming,
which I certainly wouldn't
characterize myself
as having lived a traumatized
life prior to the military,
I lived a very blessed life.
But you get to basic training,
there's a lot of people there who,
you know, it's like,
well, why are you here?
Just like, well, I was a drug addict
and I figured I wanted
this to be good place
to clean out, like seriously.
And so, and they're great guys,
they're good people within that structure.
But then it begs the question, well, what,
then the weight that is put
on your military service
is a weight that no
organization should bear.
'Cause all it takes is
one bad squad leader,
all it takes is one IED,
all it takes is one
thing which the military
and/or war will throw at you
to then demolish your identity,
demolish your purpose,
and then just make whatever
you didn't deal with,
or didn't even know you had to deal with
coming into the military,
it just exacerbates that.
And I think it's, I mean, I
guess two other short thoughts.
One is, it's amazing the mental gymnastics
that we can go through to
effectively justify the fact
that we shouldn't be wounded.
Again, the supply clerk and the FOB
who never went outside the wire,
but sees dead soldiers being
pulled off the Black Hawk
and that devastates them.
And they feel guilty,
simultaneously wounded,
because they've just been presented
with something that we
were not designed for,
which was war and death,
simultaneously with the
guilt of the fact that,
here I am not even getting shot at,
I don't even deserve
to have whatever it is
that I'm feeling, and then its stop.
And then you go to the guy
who's taking his buddy off the helicopter,
who essentially says
kind of the same thing,
which is, "Well, this is my job.
I'm still alive, Jones isn't,
so what right do I have to
feel poorly about that?"
And so, and I think a lot
of that comes back to,
it comes back to decades,
within the military,
decades of a broken cultural
narrative that you have,
people don't have a context for it,
command structures don't
have a context for it,
they're scared to death of it,
for some reasons that are good, right?
You're trying to feel
the force to go to war,
and I don't have time to
talk about people's feelings,
I'm sorry.
And if that's what,
so you get this binary response,
which is either stigmalating,
you're having a hard time,
therefore you're not fit to
deploy, that doesn't work,
or it's nothing to see
here, we're all good.
And then those things and they build,
and then you see the opt tempo
that many people across the force
have been asked to endure
over the last 20 years,
and it's staggering.
The amount of time that
people have spent in Iraq,
in Afghanistan is just incredible.
And so that's something
that we've never experienced
in America to that degree,
as far as that level and that duration
of combat exposure and war.
And so I think it is a cultural problem,
I think it's a storytelling problem
and having space to tell stories,
and just connect dots to
be able to realize that,
oh, like I'm you're, you know, yeah.
What you went through wherever,
in Afghanistan, Iraq, Vietnam,
your house where you were
molested or whatever the issue is,
what you went through is
absolutely 100% unique to you.
And your set of circumstances
and who you are as a person,
that's a unique story and,
good news, it's not unique.
Good news is there's so many people
who have experienced
that, and navigated that.
And some of those people are
people who you look up to
and admire, who for whatever reason,
you just never had the opportunity
to hear the darkness of their story.
And I experienced that a
lot as I was coming back,
just people who I saw one facet
of their military service, just like,
"Oh, you flew cobras in Vietnam, wow.
Wow, you were on the
beaches of Anzio, wow."
And then now that I'm not
some 16 year old kid anymore,
now that I, myself have
been to war and come home,
I get a whole another
facet of their story.
And I get to see, oh, wow,
like there's a whole another
dynamic that it wasn't just,
went to war, dust off your uniform,
come back and enter society
as a fully functioning adult,
there's a lot more oftentimes to that.
And so I think the more
that those stories are told,
and the more that we can get
back to changing climates
and changing cultures around that story
at the point of woundedness,
so that it's not a binary response,
it's not either you're on the bench
or you're 100% fit to go
face America's enemies,
we do that with the
physical wounds pretty well.
And so that's something
that we have to learn
to do a lot better,
but it's cultural, and I
think it's really, you know,
being able to hear and tell our stories.
- Yeah, yeah.
I really appreciate the
way you unpacked that
and just piggybacking off of
what the others had said too.
I mean, so many aspects of ways
that things have to be personalized,
both what Barbara and what Tony mentioned,
but then also just like how we responds
in those situations too.
And just, it seems there's
not a lot of gray, Steven,
in what you're saying
too, as one of the other.
And as Tony mentioned,
sometimes for a good reason,
I think as you mentioned as well,
but times also for poor
and detrimental reasons.
So I appreciate the way
you all have pulled those things out.
Our time is going quickly,
as we probably go a whole nother hour,
but I did wanna give a chance,
and Steven, you've already
started to go there already,
just to give you all time
to actually talk about,
how do we move things forward?
Barbara, I know you've done a lot of work,
some reports and testimonies
and things like that too.
There's policy, there's
culture that needs to shift,
there's the way that veterans
can just continue to counsel veterans,
as Tony has talked about.
But if you also just share
what your thoughts are
and your goals in terms
of moving things forward
so we don't just kind of get
stuck in this cycle and not to,
I mean, that is a thing that
we've talked about already,
but even in this cycle
of some of the challenges
that already exist in the
military and for veterans.
So Barbara, maybe if you
wanna lead off with that.
- Sure, and I mean,
and there's so many ways
we need to move forward.
So what you're talking about, Steven,
a lot of the stigma and
trying to let people know
it's not a weakness.
I mean, we see it as a form of resilience
to go get treatment and to work
on it and to, so, you know,
trying to deal with the stigma.
Obviously I'm working on treatments,
not every treatment works
for everybody, for sure.
And so trying to figure
out new treatments,
trying to figure out so
personalized medicine
and biomarkers and all of that,
to try to figure out
what's gonna work for whom.
And we're trying to come
up with, so for example,
we do a lot of exposure
therapy and it works very well,
but not for everyone.
So we're working on
augmentation approaches,
trying to identify early on.
I mean, we can pretty much figure
by Friday of the first week,
we can tell if someone
is on the trajectory
to get the full response or not.
So we're doing some different
things in the second week
to try to boost that response.
So I'm gonna be a lot
on the treatment front,
but I think we need to do it
all because our treatments
may not the very best
treatments in the world.
And if people won't come
forward and say, "I need help,
can you help me?" then they're
not gonna to help anyone.
So we gotta work on all of it.
- Yeah, really well said.
Steven, maybe to follow up
on what you already started to allude to,
but anything that you'd wanna add
in terms of how we move things forward?
- Yeah, I mean, I think
it's a multifaceted,
I think there's not,
you know, certainly not
one single objective
or one single initiative.
I think it's, I mean, it's, that's for me,
these conversations are super encouraging
because it pulls me out
of my own little bubble
and just reminds me
that there's, you know,
for all the things wrong with our systems.
I have a system to even complain about
which wasn't in place 30 years ago, right?
And it's not in place for
civilians in many cases.
So that was a realization
I had some time ago
where it was, you know,
whatever administrative friction there was
and seeing a counselor,
doing whatever it was,
it's just like, you know what?
There's a lot of people who've
probably seen more violence
in America than you saw in Afghanistan
who don't even have a dysfunctional
bureaucracy to turn to.
And so first off, to the extent
you can count your blessings
and then, depending on where
you're at in the world,
what can you do about it?
And I think the piece
that we're focused on
that we feel like, you know,
works to engage in, is
really that policy reform
within the active duty component.
In terms of how do we normalize the fact
that war is not good for the soul
and that there's unseen wounds
that the sooner we address them
and not just force people to
stuff them for in some cases,
20 years, so that they
don't miss promotion
or they don't miss deployment,
and then have to deal with it,
that's criminal, in my
mind, and it's stupid.
And so that's a lot of what our advocacy
in conjunction with storytelling is,
is to try and move the
needle from a policy level,
and within the DOD,
to stop weaponizing stigma,
to change policies and change culture
that can actually be influential
at the point of woundedness
and not years after the fact.
There was a film made.
I think one of the most
instructive things, culturally,
is there was a film made, that
some of you may be aware of,
by John Huston, a World War II,
called "Let There be Light".
And you can watch that
film, I think, on Netflix,
I think it's still on the platform,
but in that film, he
tells the story of this,
essentially a field
hospital that was set up,
I think it was in Long Island,
for folks coming back from
the Pacific and Europe
who were experiencing acute
trauma from their experiences.
And you watch, in 50
minutes, in black and white,
you watch these folks have
those wounds acknowledged
and you see what,
how they change in two or three weeks
before we send them back to their home.
And it's powerful.
And it's not to say that those are the,
those modalities to
treatment or maybe crude,
but just having those wounds
acknowledged within a cohort,
like you talked about,
Tony, within community,
before just being unleashed
back in the civilian in world,
is so essential.
The night that that
film was to be screened,
the DOD paid for it.
The night that that
film was to be screened
at the Museum of Modern Art in New York,
it was confiscated by MPs,
and it was classified until
the Carter administration.
- Wow.
- Nobody saw it until it was declassified.
And that film, which was
honest, and it was hope-filled,
was replaced by another DOD
film called "Shades of Gray",
which essentially, the message was,
if you're a good red blooded American,
you really shouldn't have a problem
meeting the communist hoard dead on.
It's very difficult to watch.
It's pandering, it's ignorant,
it's insulting, frankly,
it's almost cartoonish.
But all that to say is, whether
that was explicit or not.
That was a film that was
made out of a lot of fear
based on the next threat that
we saw towards our nation,
and that idea permeates.
So for us, it's, you know,
you don't fix that with
one movie or one book
or one conversation, but how do you engage
to shift that narrative back
to something that maybe is hard
to look at look at, both at an individual
and a societal level because
there's a lot of failure,
there's a lot of regret, but
there's also a lot of hope.
And so really that's where
we feel like we can engage,
is in that storytelling dynamic
and hopefully moving the needle
with national policy change,
knowing that if all of our hope
is based on Congress changing
policy, we're in bad shape.
And so the work of Dr.
Rothbaum and Tony and others
in the community, day in day
out, is absolutely essential.
Like that's so encouraging
because that doesn't take
Congress getting its act together.
We can (indistinct) right
now, in our community,
so that's super encouraging to me.
- Thanks so much for sharing all that.
I mean that's, well,
that story that you shared
about the films that's,
well, I'm still, I mean,
just the impacts of that.
It also makes me think that we
need to do more to highlight
what Dr. Rothbaum is doing as well.
If we can summarize, as you
mentioned the beginning,
'cause I mean,
that sounds like it was
also part of that first film
that was just not let out
and just the power of that,
and Dr. Rothbaum, you talked
about from the effectiveness.
So Steven, thanks for pulling
out those those nuances
and just being frank about the
realities in a lot of ways.
- Yeah, but also highlighting
a message of hope,
'cause I do think that that's
what we need to put out there,
is a message of hope.
- A 100% agreed.
Tony, you get the last word.
- So being a military guy
and prior NCO, it's not,
let's don't talk about, let's be about it.
And the thing is I want, as far as policy,
I wanna replicate what the DOD has
and put it on the veterans' world.
So that includes families,
so Why I have this
family thing going, okay?
That includes family.
We gotta take what worked in the DOD world
and replicate it, and it's
gonna take grassroots, okay?
So that's fine with me.
If I gotta start it, fine.
But I think we gotta start
looking at not just a veteran
as being the person you look at,
but look at the family as well,
because sometimes you want
gun safety go to the spouse
and they'll be more
likely accept gun safety
than the veteran, all right?
But we just stuck on the veteran
and we trying to convince him that,
oh no, it's good for you.
So policy on that, that
I keep talking about.
Also about the locality,
being local, local, local.
We cannot nationalize,
we cannot monopolize,
cannot franchise this, okay?
You gotta start with the local community
and that's where your funding has to be.
Okay, so the funding just
can't come from one source
and then you try it,
and then you have like one
or two people covering the
whole state of Florida,
to try to do some kinda outreach.
You gotta start bringing in the community,
'cause the community is them.
We are no longer,
people don't understand
that we're veteran,
we're no longer federalized.
So when you have, when you
try to do something to me,
you better make sure you do the same thing
to anybody else who's American citizen.
And when I'm a DOD,
I'm a federal employee,
but as a veteran, I'm an individual.
So if you're not gonna
take their guns away,
you're not gonna take my guns away.
And I'm just saying what I hear.
I'm not saying that, I'm just saying,
don't say, I am not a
federal piece of property,
I'm a constituent.
So treat us like constituents
of your community,
that means the county,
the state, the city,
and the state and federal
all have to play a part
in taking care of me, not
just the federal government.
So those are the things that I,
and when I mentioned with Steven,
and I agree with that when it
comes to he's a policy guy.
I think we have a problem
with Congress right now
because of the two partisan.
So it's gotta start
here, at the grassroots,
where everybody's gonna
take care of the veteran.
And finally, when I see a
battle full of political bodies,
I don't sit there and start
look at the percentages
of who's out there, okay?
I just see a veteran out
there that's laying out,
needing help, needing care.
I don't see if it's a female,
I don't see if it's an African American,
I just see a veteran out
there that needs help.
We need to bring that
down to us eventually,
where we also see a veteran
out there that needs
versus these little things
that they put us into that, you know,
to try to put us in a box.
So those are my two things, that is,
spend more money to the community,
don't forget the families from
kinds of policies, that's me.
Be about it, don't not just
talk about it, but be about it.
- Yep, yep.
Exactly.
Well, I know we did talk about hoping,
for me, just having this conversation
gives me a hope as well.
I mean, in multiple ways, just
how frank you all have been
about the challenges,
but then also the ways that
things have moved forward
and the ways that we can
continue to move things forward.
And it's also, I'm grateful
that even this conversation
is encouraging to you all,
as you're seeing different pockets
of the work that's being done.
So again, I'm honored that I've been able
to host this conversation,
to be able to step into this community,
if only for a brief moment,
but hopefully not for a fleeting moment
and something that we can all
continue to be engaged in.
Again, grateful to all
of you for being here
for the work that you all
are doing, continue to do,
and just for the impact that
it's having in so many lives.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, thank you.
And thank you for helping
us get the word out
- Of course.
(upbeat music)